Speaker 1: So you all know I like a good
conspiracy theory. Not just because I don't
know. Sometimes they're entertaining, but the way
people come to believe things is very interesting.
But also the sort of suspension of disbelief, the
lack of skepticism that sometimes goes with some
conspiracy theories is also really interesting.
And I don't know if it has to do with the sort of
commitment and desperation to believe something or
what. But we're going to look at an example here,
our friends over at The Good Liars,
in fact, Jason from The Good Liars.
Spoke to a guy who believes that John F Kennedy is
still alive and currently president of the United
States. Now we're going to play the clip. Some
of you may remember the JFK stuff has actually
been sort of prominent over the last couple of
years. And one of the really funny things is
there's lots of people who have bought into
the JFK conspiracy theories, but they're a
little bit confused about John F Kennedy, the
guy who was president versus John F Kennedy Jr.
And there is this really funny clip I played for
you a few months ago of protesters saying JFK
is the president and then they go. Wait, do you
mean JFK jr. And they go, Yeah. No. They're like
arguing with each other as to which one it
is because they don't really remember. Okay,
so that's the set. Here's another guy who says,
right now JFK is the president and JFK Jr is the
vice president, which is a new spin on this one.
Speaker 2: Well, in the short to us, Donald Trump,
John F Kennedy and John carney junior as he's
vice president. He's the vice president. Kennedy's
are president. So you got to explain this. You
gotta explain this to me. So so John F Kennedy
senior is president right now. Senior president
right now. Is you being serious right now?
I'm being serious. And didn't he because
remember in Dallas, he was he was riding
and then somebody shot in. His brains went all
over Jackie O. Yeah, something like that. But
that did. You're saying that didn't happen?
Speaker 1: Right. That didn't happen. So the
reason I love this one is there's two layers.
It's not new that people sometimes claim
John F Kennedy wasn't really killed right. In in
1963 in Dallas. It just didn't happen that way.
And in fact, there's actually more than that.
There's he was killed, but not by Lee Harvey
Oswald or not only by Lee Harvey Oswald. Okay.
So that's like one set of things. Then you go
to he wasn't actually killed at all and okay. But
like, imagine that he hadn't been killed at all.
But then there's the wackiest part, which is
John F Kennedy would be 105 years old right now.
And that's where it actually starts to get funny
because many of these people are confused about
JFK versus JFK. Jr JFK, if he were still alive,
today would be 62 years old. I'm sorry. JFK jr.
John f kennedy would be 105 years old today if
he were still alive. So if you can get beyond he
wasn't really assassinated, which already takes
a lot. Anything involving john f kennedy senior
today. You're talking about a man who would be 105
years old. And that particular element seems to be
completely missing from the critical thinking of
these individuals now, beyond beyond that kind of
funny thing. I don't really know why the JFK stuff
has has seen a resurgence in the last year and a
half as related to Donald Trump. And, I mean,
I'm open to hearing from people why you think
that we've seen all sorts of conspiracy theories
relating to Trump, like Trump is truly still the
president. The military is still under the control
of Donald Trump. There's a shadow government,
whatever. Right. Okay, fine. But Trump's in his
mid seventies, so it's plausible. Why all of a
sudden shifting to the would be now hundred and
five year old John F Kennedy? It doesn't make
any sense to me. Maybe it's just things go in
cycles and we're back to JFK one way or another.
Maybe it'll happen again. When JFK would have been
120 years old in 15 years, I don't know. But let
me know your thoughts as to why the JFK stuff is
such a big deal to so many of these Trump people